neighbour was a serial killer mosselmate
was a satanist he's got a satanic
inverted pentagram tattooed on his
forehead and for murder part of a cult
that's drinking blood and eating human
body parts
and he was actually very nice to me this
is shawn atwood he was a millionaire
stockbroker in the 1990s after bringing
the rave scene to arizona he became a
drug kingpin and ran his own
international drug smuggling operation a
shy kid growing up he was often bullied
at school and nearly got beaten to death
by some drunks at a gas station
after he graduated from university he
flew to arizona made millions in the
stock market started his own drug
business and was dubbed the bank of
england at one point he even ended up on
sammy gravano's hit list after a series
of events he was eventually arrested and
ended up in one of the worst prisons in
america
this is the insane story of how a
millionaire stockbroker became a drug
kingpin
sean atwood was born on october 28 1968.
he grew up in the small chemical
manufacturing town of witness northwest
england at school he was a bit of a nerd
and often got bullied but even from a
young age sean began to show his
potential during lunch breaks he would
often read the financial times with the
help of a teacher who translated the
complex numbers and business jargon sean
made his first investment in the stock
market at just 16 years old using his
own pocket money when he was a teenager
sean flew to arizona to visit his two
aunts
unsurprisingly when the young pale
englishman stepped off the plane he was
dazzled by the bright sun and instantly
fell in love with america the luxury
houses swimming pools and the blue skies
america was the promised land and it
instilled in him a burning desire to
become successful back in england sean
did as his parents advised completing a
levels in maths physics and economics at
school before going on to do a degree in
business studies at the university of
liverpool one day while he was filling
up his car at a gas station some drunks
started to abuse him one of the
attackers took an iron bar and smashed
his teeth in he thought he was getting
killed he went unconscious and woke up
in a pool of his own blood he eventually
went to the hospital to get treated
after the incident he suffered from
anxiety and became very self-conscious
during the late 80s a new music scene
swept across the uk
sean was captured by the wide-eyed
youngsters in psychedelic clothing
partying at raves
during his final year at university sean
was asked by a friend from his economics
class to go to a party in manchester at
the party sean tried ecstasy and speed
for the first time his anxiety went away
and he was making friends with half the
people at the club
the one-off event quickly became more
regular every weekend shawn and his
friends would join a convoy of cars
heading to illegal raves
however he didn't let his new hobby get
in the way of his lifelong dream in the
summer of 1990 after graduating from
university he boarded a plane straight
to arizona
for around six years sean worked as a
stockbroker high pressure telesales with
brokers cursing and screaming on the
telephone he was a fast learner and
excelled as a stockbroker he even had a
whole team working under him and began
earning hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year
on the weekends sean blew off steam by
throwing parties at his apartment he
started buying 50 xtc pills at a time
from a local dealer and gave them away
to his friends
soon he pledged to bring the uk rave
scene to arizona
stockbroking became too much for him
then in 1997 he left his firm and poured
most of his savings into technology
shares
the shares shot up at the height of the
dotcom bubble and shawn's portfolio was
worth more than two million dollars
at the same time he began using his
wealth to organize bigger raves he
became frustrated with the small-time
local dealers so he drove to la to see
what he could buy from someone higher up
in the chain
for a few years sean built up the
infrastructure of his drug dealing
business solely using ecstasy sourced
from la
he hired a team of people and gave them
cars and apartments
but after a while sean was curious as to
where the ecstasy pills were sourced
from he found out that the pills were
coming from a production plant in
holland
so he sent some of his people over to
try and source the ecstasy pills shawn's
mules would carry around 5000 pills at a
time but as they became more confident
the number went up to 40 000 pills per
smuggling mission back then airport
security wasn't as strict as it is today
and they didn't even know what ecstasy
looked like
in one incident one of his drug meals
got stopped by security they took out
the ecstasy pills and asked her what
they were the drug mule said they were
just vitamin pills the security put the
ecstasy pills back in her luggage and
told her to have a nice flight back in
arizona shawn's business was soaring he
earned the nickname the bank of england
and his ecstasy pills were dubbed
english shawns he even gained protection
from the new mexican mafia after
protecting a gang member called g-dog
from the cops sean didn't know it yet
but he was dealing with one of the most
violent gangs in arizona
with a free protection of a powerful
criminal gang and the false confidence
instilled by increasingly regular drug
use shawn got a bit too comfortable his
competitor in the ecstasy market was
sammy the bull gravano a mafia murderer
and former underboss of the gambino
crime family gravano's crew members
attempted to kill sean and many of his
associates one night gravano's crew
members were dispatched to kidnap shawn
from a nightclub to take him out to the
desert to have him killed but luckily
sean's best friend wild man got into a
fight that night and they had to leave
the club in a hurry
after the conflict sean stopped dealing
and gave up his ecstasy business
in 2001 sean fell in love his girlfriend
at the time claudia convinced him to
clean up his act persuaded he began
trading stocks online he thought he'd
gotten away with years of criminal
activity unscathed but unfortunately for
him in arizona police had seven years to
convict him and they didn't require
physical evidence of the drugs
themselves it turned out that police had
been aware of sean's drug business for
years
tapping phone calls and gathering
witness statements
in may 2002 sean was arrested and faced
a 200-year sentence in america's
deadliest prison
the jail was run by sheriff joe arpaio
also known as the angel of death after
serving two years in maricopa county
jail prior to sentencing sean pled
guilty to a sentence of nine and a half
years and was banned for life from
entering the united states he detailed
dead rats in the food cockroaches
crawling in his ears at night gang
mayhem and violence even the guards were
murdering the prisoners
during this time shawn lost about 28
pounds due to the unbearable food
after signing a plea bargain sean was
moved to the arizona department of
corrections the prison was completely
gang controlled fights often broke out
and at one point he even saw an inmate
get beheaded
his first cellmate was a satanist put in
jail for murder he was part of a cult
that drank blood and ate human body
parts his prison guard then decided to
play a prank he moved sean to a new cell
where his new cellmate was a serial home
invader who had been convicted for
breaking into people's homes and
smashing their kneecaps in with hammers
for sean the prison was hell on earth in
his free time sean began to read he read
around a thousand books in just over six
years
with his newfound love of reading came a
desire to write
he began an anonymous blog called john's
jail journal the blog which was sneaked
out and published by sean's visitors
exposed the terrible conditions of the
jail riots stabbings and rapes it
received national media attention in
2007 sean was released from prison he
went back to the uk and moved into his
parents house even at home he received
numerous phone calls from people he'd
met in prison asking him to help
establish a drug importation business to
the uk but sean declined and chose to
start a new life
since leaving prison sean became a
best-selling author and has published a
wide variety of books including one
about the famous colombian drug kingpin
pablo escobar he also gave a ted talk
started a youtube channel and even hosts
a podcast he's also become a strong
proponent against the war on drugs
he tours schools across the uk educating
children on the risks related to illegal
drugs
he also does a lot of charity work for
local communities he's become a changed
man who's completely turned his life
around
from millionaire stockbroker to drug
kingpin what can we learn from sean
atwood's insane journey
it goes without saying that the drug
business is a dangerous one and while
drugs are glorified by pop culture they
can have serious consequences
but one thing we can all learn from sean
atwood is his resilience he has faced so
much adversity in his life from being
bullied at school and nearly beaten to
death to surviving one of the toughest
prisons in america he always found a way
to keep going and never gave up in a
tough situation and by writing books and
giving talks he's able to share his
experience and highlight the dangers of
the drug business
what do you guys think are drugs
glorified in pop culture and should
countries end the war on drugs the
comment section in this one will be very
interesting
if you guys want to support the channel
feel free to check out our patreon well
you'll get access to exclusive content
monthly q a's discord benefits video
scripts and more every dollar will be
reinvested back into the channel your
contributions will massively improve the
quality of our content link is in the
description
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one